der berühmte kämpfer herakles aus dem
alten rom hat uns ein was gutes getan
nachhaltig wie sie junge was los ist
mickey mouse club willkommen bayern ein
video und zwar geht es heute um fünf
arten von unterricht ich hab mir das
ganze ein bisschen unterstützung von
meinem kumpel deswegen wundert euch
nicht wenn gleichzeitig noch irgendwer
anderes sehen hier vielleicht nicht
kennt auf jeden fall wünsche euch viel
spaß mit dem video das auf jeden fall
doch nach oben da mein zeug gefällt und
so das war es auch schon viel spaß jetzt
und voll rein ich moderiere das jetzt so
ein bisschen an so was jetzt kommt
einfach an sonst wäre es ein bisschen
wird also ich würde sagen wir fangen
einfach man mit der ersten
unterrichtsform und zwar ist das also
diese hier viel spaß so liebe schüler
herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen schub
alex trinken weg schuldig
hab ich vergessen wir zum ersten mal
oder was wo ist denn der hat überhaupt
jetzt sein sitznachbar der schon gestern
gefehlt also ich dass es steckten unter
einer decke
es muss ich sofort notieren so alex
mache ich jetzt mal nützlich okay ich
hatte ja chinesisch wir haben gestern
das chemische tode von harald peters
besprochen genau bitte schnell zwar vor
tut mir leid aber das kann ich nicht
viel da habe ich zu hause vergessen was
ich mir da jetzt sortieren volkswagen
nach umsonst rufe ich deine eltern an
wegen einer fehlenden hausaufgaben nicht
die ersten dieser woche und es gab am
montag so das machen wir schon weiter
und zwar ich will es auch ein zu viel
verraten aber ihr kennt bestimmt diesen
unterricht da denkt okay der lehrer muss
es jetzt auch nicht übertreiben mit dem
was halt so den stoff angeht deswegen
viel spaß oder hiermit so liebe schüler
david morgan 2011 wieder unterricht habe
ich ein paar arbeitsblätter mitgenommen
bitte bis morgens arbeiten ansonsten
folgt dieselbe strafe gemacht wieder
wenn ihr erstes album nur die geduldig
machbar
bis morgen bearbeiten so dann kommen wir
auch schon zu der dritten art von
unterricht und zwar kennt ihr das
bestimmt alle außerdem megathlon von
euch
man sitzt so in manchen fächern da und
denkt sich so ok warum jetzt warum jetzt
das und das warum das und dass man
mannschaft einfach gar nichts hier sehen
wir ein element besteht immer aus
protonen elektronen neue varianten mal
ganz ehrlich verstehst du irgendwas was
ob du irgendwas verstehst du ja dann
würde ich sagen wir kommen zu
unterrichten nummer vier
viel spaß vielleicht erhaltet ihr hier
hat das ist schreibt in die kommentare
falls ja sagen meine schüler ich hoffe
dir sie sind alle mitgekommen
das ist sehr sehr wichtig fürs weitere
leben
gucken sie sich bitte das modell erneut
an
konzentrieren sie sich am besten dass es
1 1 das modell basiert bei vorlesung
alex ich glaube ich gestatte unterricht
zu abwechslungsreich wie möglich
und dann sind wir jetzt auch schon bei
unterricht art nummer fünf und ich will
nicht zu viel verraten aber es gibt halt
auch so die lehrer da ist es egal ob wir
da bist oder nicht
kennt ihr bestimmt auch so viel spaß
dies noch nicht da noch kein bergbau man
muss schon wieder machen das haben wir
doch erst letzte woche gemacht und davor
die machen auch glaube ich ja ohne
scherz jetzt wirklich du weißt selber
seit sieben wochen bearbeiten wir das
selber arbeitsplatz abgesehen davon weiß
nicht mal wie ich heiße mann
sollte das weiß doch langer zeit mal
wieder eine etwas andere art von video
auf jeden fall ich habe eben schon
gesagt weil sich gefallen hat was auf
jeden fall noch nach oben da von meinem
kumpel checkte hier könnt ihr hier
seinen zeh abdecken und hier auf der
anderen seite ist mein job und abo nicht
vergessen um nichts zu verpassen hier
auf der linken seite geht's jetzt weiter
mit meinem metz video das war dinge die
mädchen an jungs sie verstehen teil 3
und hier auf der anderen seite kommt die
zu einem alten video von uns beiden
dabei auch schon mal dabei checkt auch
auf jeden fall ab ist schon bestimmt
dreiviertel jahr oder so und ja sonst
sehen wir uns dann halt am samstag
wieder rein